that's kind of because again I'm doing
the documentary on the court system here
and I'm starting to like learn
um you don't even have to be married
it's a crazy thing it's just with a kid
um just the that guys go through
um especially with getting access to
their kids and they can get a lot of
false accusations because here
um they're literally paid they're given
free counsel if you accuse guy of
assault and a lot of the centers here
know that so they encourage the women to
do it
um yeah and even though it doesn't
happen to every guy I have like
listening to these stories I'm like if I
was like I would be so I've heard a lot
of stories like that from clients where
like basically like like women that
cheat for instance if the the husband
finds out like I've heard of a lot of
situations where the guy
um gets screwed because the woman just
says you know the guy that hooked up the
woman just says like it was
non-consensual just so she can save the
marriage